95% der Kinder die in die Schule kommen
haben eigentlich die Grundimmunisierung
hinter sich aber bei bestimmten
Erkrankung ist das Vertrauen in
Impfungen zurückgegangen vor einigen
Jahren war gab es noch 1000 1500
Todesfälle durch Masern die
Masernimpfung ist jetzt immer noch 76 %
erst bei Kindern jetzt das Jahrgang 2018
die haben sie diese zweite Impfung
bekommen und dieses schlechte
kommunizieren das Festhalten an falschen
Thesen falsche Informationen
diskreditieren die nicht nur die
corona-impfung an sich oder die
corona-bekämpfungsmaßnahmen jetzt für
den Herbst man muss ja auch wieder was
tun es wird sicherlich noch eine heftige
winterwelle geben dieses Vertrauen das
verloren geht wenn man einmal eine
bestimmte Sache nicht auf die Reihe
bekommen hat wenn man also jetzt das
Vertrauen in die corona-impfung
untergräbt unser gräbt man gleichzeitig
nicht nur das Vertrauen in die Impfungen
an sich sondern auch das Vertrauen in
die Gesundheitspolitik der Regierung